and Tom Brady kind of hit on it it was a
clip going around last week Tom Brady
saying there's a lot of mocy in today's
NFL and let's listen I think there's a
lot of mediocrity in today's NFL I don't
see the Excellence that I saw in the
past why not and why not I think the
coaching isn't as as good as it was I
don't think the development of young
players is as good as it was the rules
have allowed a lot of bad habits to get
into the actual performance of the game
so I just think the product in my
opinion is less than what it's been I
think I look at a lot of players like
Ray Lewis and Rodney Harrison and Ronnie
lot and guys that impacted the game in
in a certain way and every hit they
would have made would have been a
penalty you hear coaches complaining
about their own player being tackling
and not necessarily why don't they talk
to their player about how to protect
himself we used to work on the
fundamental those things all the time
now they're trying to be regulated all
the time offensive players need to
protect themselves it's not up to the
defensive player to protect offensive
player a defensive player needs to
protect himself I didn't throw the ball
to certain areas because I was afraid
players going to get knocked out mhm
that's the reality I didn't throw it to
the middle when I played Ray Lewis
because you knock him out of the game
and I couldn't afford to lose a good
player I I kind of H without a doubt
100% agree um you look at today's NFL
with a lot of QB flopping on hits uh
you're looking at guys who are you know
kind of flailing they they hit them hard
they Le with their shoulder and it looks
like it's a helmet to helmet they get
fine 40,000 they're trying to protect
these guys um The Blind Side hits I
agree should be taken out um but there's
a lot of things a lot of hits that you
can make you can't leave your feet when
you're making a hit um this is 100%
correct they're protecting a certain
amount of guys uh so that way they like
a guy perfect example uh Kareem
Jackson's been fined an absurd amount
absurd amount this year I believe over
$100,000 um and all the hits he made
were very legal hits but because guys
are trying to SL or they don't know how
to protect themselves or they're not
sliding in time they are finding this
man and suspending this man of games
because he is playing football the right
way uh I think Tom even at a point in
his career he he took advantage of the
rule change and he let that be in his
favor he let these rules that they knew
they were changing into his favor even
cha would look for cuse and say uh you
know you know and this is true Tom will
look for late hits he will look for you
know uh if
if his wide receiver got hit the wrong
way and he would sometimes get those
calls and that's just the reality of it
the league has went more into the
offensive League they're trying to
protect and keep QBs because guys like
DeShaun Watson are out for the rest of
the Year Joe burrow uh kurk cousins
they're trying to do their best to
protect these guys and lead them on the
field and that's just the reality I
don't think that the league is trending
the right way and you kind of see it a
little bit in college football college
football has been going downhill a lot
you know High School football has been
going down the hill lot and it's just
been uh streaming upwards they like it
it's like a trail that never ends of bad
football being played from high school
all the way up from the Tendencies the
coaching has not been uh right they
haven't been teaching these guys mowing
these guys into men uh teaching these
guys the fundamentals of what it means
to be a player on and off the field and
that's just the reality of it and it and
it's leaking into the NFL and it's just
getting worse and worse um and I just
don't think it's the same love and
protection towards defensive players at
that uh so it
I 100% agree with Tom I think there's
players and there's teams that takes
advantage of these rules uh the fact
that you know a quarterback could run at
you full speed One play and give himself
up and then the next time act like he's
sliding or he may you may think he's
about to slide and he could Juke out and
you go with the same energy and you hit
him because you don't know if he's fake
sliding or he is sliding and you might
get a penalty and you might get a letter
in the mail because you you late hit
this quarterback I just think it's
outright ridiculous like
like there you either can hit the guy or
you can't like I don't think there
should be a uh in andout there shouldn't
be a certain rule where oh well if he
gives himself up well you're playing
football at full speed you're not
playing football at 50% like I think
that's the retive like you're playing
football to hit the other team and get
your team in the best position to win
you're not worried about what this guy's
doing like I'm not I can't focus on
tackling this guy while I'm focused on
oh my go this guy sliding I need to get
this guy to the ground um so this is
this is something that's mindboggling to
me um it's like very short gaps and
there's very and especially there's ones
when the quarterback's throwing it out
you're pass ruping you're clearing a guy
and just as you get there you're hitting
the QB or you might try to sack him
thinking he's still the ball um and you
could get a flag and you get the rering
passes so guys are you know almost
scared or you got to make sure the QB
has the ball uh that Split Second can be
different so you get to sacker not so I
think this is the truth and the reality
of this uh but you know I I 100% agree
on what Tom Brady's
saying